THOMAS WOOLLEY: OK, so today
we're going to be talking
about the number 3/4, or 0.75.
Unusual, I know, because it's
not a whole number,
like 0, 1, 2, 3, 4.
But this one is very important
in biology.
So Max Kleiber in the 1930s
posited a graph of mass of
animal against metabolic rate.
Down here we have the mouse,
he'll have his little legs
there and little ears.
MALE SPEAKER: Is that a mouse?
THOMAS WOOLLEY: That's
a mouse.
MALE SPEAKER: That's the worst
mouse I've ever seen.
THOMAS WOOLLEY: Wait until
you see my elephant.
So somewhere up here,
1,000 times heavier,
you'll have an elephant.
So let's try this one.
MALE SPEAKER: That's not bad.
THOMAS WOOLLEY: That's
not bad.
Well, you know, it's
kind of like a big
mouse, to be honest.
And then all the way up here,
you have your blue whale.
OK, so he plotted the mass
against the metabolic rate of
all the animals.
So mouse, elephant, blue
whale, there was
also mayflies in there.
And as you might expect, with
the bigger animals, they need
more energy to survive.
And that's what metabolic rate
essentially measures.
How much energy do you
need to survive?
So small animals need a small
amount of energy, bigger
animals need more energy.
So one way it could happen is
that since the elephant is
1,000 times heavier than the
mouse, it would need 1,000
times much more energy.
And if you had that sort of
scaling, it would be linear.
And so it would have just a
straight line between the
metabolic rate and the mass.
So the whale, that's a million
heavier than the mouse, so it
would need a million
times more energy.
Or it could be super linear.
So the elephant is 1,000 times
heavier than the mouse, so it
needs, say, a million
times more.
It actually needs more than
the line originally, the
linear line.
What Max Kleiber found was that
it's neither of those.
The curve actually tapers
off, and so it's below
the straight line.
What that means is that the
bigger you get, although you
need more energy, you can spend
it more efficiently.
So down here, with your mayflies
and your spiders and
all your insects, they need very
little energy, but they
don't use it very efficiently.
And this scale crosses all sizes
of animal, right down to
cells, all the way up
to the blue whale.
It's amazing how this curve
describes all the animals.
And how does this curve
link in the 3/4?
Well, what Max found was that
this curve, is that the
metabolic rate is proportional
to the mass to power 3/4.
Now, statistically, it was
around 3/4, so it's something
like 0.74 or 0.76.
But on average, that's what
biologists now take.
So this is Kleiber's rule,
or the 3/4 rule.
Well, when they found 3/4, one
thing we want to understand is
where does that number
come from?
Is it just a coincidence that
it's 3/4, or is this some
reasoning behind it that
we can get at?
So originally when they were
looking for this 3/4, they
were trying to link metabolic
rate and the mass.
And so your metabolic rate is
how much you use energy.
And you use energy, they
thought, mostly through
heating yourself.
And so what affects the heat?
Well, your surface area.
The bigger your surface area,
the more you lose heat.
And the bigger you are in terms
of your mass, again, the
more heat you will have.
So they looked at spherical
animals.
So just for the sake of
mathematics, we're going to
treat these animals as spheres,
because your main
body is sort of spherical.
And you can at least get an
approximation of what you'd
expect to get at the end.
We draw our sphere, and we
give it a radius, r.
So that's the body of
the animal, OK?
So even if you're a mayfly,
you'd be a tiny sphere.
If you're a blue whale, you'd
be an enormous sphere.
So the area, the surface area
of this sphere, that's
proportional to r squared.
As you increase r, if you double
r, your surface area
increases by 4.
And the volume of the sphere
is proportional to r cubed.
So if you double the
radius, your volume
increases by eight.
So using this idea that the
metabolic rate is proportional
to these two guys, you'd expect
it to be metabolic rate
is proportional to r 2/3.
So you'd get a 2/3 power out.
So although 2/3 is quite close
to 3/4, we wanted to
understand where that difference
is coming from,
because they're close.
So it's a good first
approximation, but there has
to be some reason that we're
not getting 3/4.
And so what mathematicians have
looked at is using the
fractal structure inside us
to deliver that energy.
So the circulation system that
we have, the veins, the
arteries, and the
capillaries, is
self-similar all the way down.
As you zoom into the
veins, they look
like the whole system.
And that's what a fractal is.
And using that fractal
structure, you can link the
mass to the elephant
to the blue whale.
And that does spits out
the 3/4 power law
at the end of it.
So as I said, yeah, the bigger
the animal, the more efficient
you're using your energy.
But using this idea of the
circulation system being a
fractal, you can then start
using it to look at cities,
because what are cities?
Well, they've got their own
circulation system, because
they have roads that deliver
cars to places.
They have water pipes, they
have electricity cables.
And you can plot those certain
things against population, and
you get very similar graphs that
follow this power rule.
It may not be 3/4, but you'll
get that it's proportional to
the population, and it's
less than linear.
And they usually are following
a quarter structure.
So whatever this number may be
on top, you'll usually find a
4 on the bottom.